hallo leute heute möchten wir mit euch
darüber sprechen warum es so schwer ist
vokabeln zu lernen
wenn ihr eine neue sprache lernt dann
müsst ihr euch viele dinge merken dativ
positiv trennbare werben oder
präpositionen aber eine herausforderung
die immer wieder habt und die auch immer
bleibt ist es vokabeln zu lernen um die
deutsche sprache fließend auf einem
einfachen niveau zu sprechen müsst ihr
mindestens 3000 vokabellernen und das
ist echt viel gleichzeitig ist unser
erinnerungsvermögen jedoch beschränkt
wir können und wollen uns gar nicht die
tausenden informationen merken die wir
jeden tag aufnehmen
was ist aber wenn wir uns etwas
unbedingt merken wollen es aber einfach
nicht in unserem gedächtnis bleibt
wie ihr vielleicht wisst arbeite ich
zusammen mit einem amerikaner namens
jeremy und wir arbeiten an einer app zum
deutsch lernen
jeremy hatte das gleiche problem immer
wieder dass ihr wahrscheinlich kennt
hier ist eine szene aus unserem alltag
[Musik]
du wirst wohl übermütig jamie über mutig
was heißt das denn immer mit sich heißt
so was wie wo wann welche es vielleicht
über gut also du hast zu viel mut ja
übermut
[Musik]
juli in dieser szene habt ihr gesehen
wie jeremy in einer ganz natürlichen
situation ein neues wort lernt und zwar
übermütig nachdem er dieses wort einmal
gelernt hat kann er es schon wenige
minuten später selbst anwenden
doch wie lange bleibt so ein neues wort
eigentlich im gedächtnis
ich höre ich erhöhe auch ich für machbar
[Musik]
ich gehe ich bin dabei
haha dieses mal aber verdammt wie heißt
dieses wort nach übermäßig ja übermut
ich warum ist so papa nennen so schwer
in unserer zweiten szene habt ihr
gesehen wie einfach es ist wörter wieder
zu vergessen
vor ein paar tagen noch hatte jeremy das
wort übermütig gelernt ein paar tage
später konnte er sich jedoch nicht mehr
an das wort erinnern wie genau
funktioniert das also mit dem erinnern
und dem vergessen
der deutsche psychologe hermann
ebbinghaus hat schon vor über hundert
jahren zu diesem thema geforscht und
einige interessante sachen
herausgefunden
jamie hat darüber mal ein video für euch
gemacht
[Musik]
angefangen an sie länger zu arbeiten
weil er daran glaubt dass man software
benutzen kann um noch effizienter eine
sprache zu lernen
und gerade beim vokabellernen kann eine
software wirklich effektiv sein und
gerade deshalb haben wir in den
vergangenen monaten an einem neuen
vokabeltrainer gearbeitet den wir euch
heute vorstellen möchten
[Musik]
und jetzt freuen wir uns total wenn ihr
den neuen vokabeltrainer auch mal
ausprobiert hier könnt ihr direkt zu
sehen das ganze ausprobieren lasst uns
auch einen kommentar hier unten denn
wenn immer ihr einen kommentar habt
können wir die software weiter
verbessern und wir freuen uns auf euer
feedback tschüss und bis zur nächsten
woche
[Musik]